what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are currently at NASA's I pack the
infrared processing and analysis Center
and as you can see behind us we have a
bunch of servers and data storage and
that is holding all of the infrared data
and of the Spitzer Space Telescope and
the exoplanet archive data and who
better to be talking about exoplanets
with than dr. Jessie Christianson thank
you for coming out of the show
hi Ellen thank you for having me and
Jesse was also with us about a year and
a half ago we featured her and Jesse
rocks and she's definitely at the
forefront of categorizing and cataloging
and taking certain exoplanets out
putting putting other updating ones this
is a really important part of space and
part of science and so we're gonna be
unpacking this for you and actually it's
a very funny time because it's currently
the XO kal which is the exoplanet
conference of Southern California and
you know about like a hundred of these
really prominent scientists and
exoplanet field that are congregating
right now and talking about the field
which is exploding because Kepler has
now had thousands of exoplanet
discoveries and now we're moving into
tests anyway we're gonna break that all
down right now jesse has five years at
the NASA exoplanet archive as a research
scientist where she's doing all this
cataloguing and why don't we talk about
because you did it you did PhD in
astrophysics and astronomy at at New
South Wales in Australia and since then
you've had this move to LA you've been
doing this five years now tell us about
you got two young ones that you got to
mold their minds into the world this is
tough stuff like balancing all this out
and being at the cutting edge of space
so maybe tell us a bit about like the
last five years in the space and how
it's been sure thank you okay so the
last five years so I moved from New
South Wales to Boston for two years to
do my postdoc at Harvard then I went to
San Francisco for a few years to work on
Kepler and now I've been here for five
years
balancing finding planets and look
after my children is a tough act I will
say but it's been a really exciting time
in exoplanets exoplanets are really
having this exponential growth in the
number of planets we've found you can
actually follow it with time and the
doubling time is about 27 months so
every twenty seven months is twice as
many exoplanets that we know about them
before and that trend we think is only
going to continue over the next few
years with the launch of tests as you
mentioned and later the W first mission
which is going to launch in the next
decade so yeah it's been a challenge but
it's been a super exciting time in a
super exciting challenge damn so we're
doubling the amount of exoplanets every
27 months wow that's exciting because it
used to be like zero yeah yeah and that
was what like pre 2005 it was 1995 okay
yeah 1995 we were just like we don't
know what's really orbiting other stars
and now we're like we know we know more
we know a little bit okay that's crazy
that we're gaining that many numbers
doubling every 27 months that's crazy
cool and there's this seems to be no you
know it's Moore's law there's so many of
these like you know biologies having
sequencing drop in price now like that
as well
it's so interesting how technology is
helping us with this process
yeah across industries as well which is
very exciting exponential technology
thank goodness
okay so let's talk just a bit about you
know transit photometry work we're at
the infrared processing and analysis
Center infrared is different than
photometry and and so just being able to
see on an infrared part of the spectrum
versus being able to just see light
maybe tell us a bit about maybe that
difference and then tell us about this
transit photometry where you're actually
seeing the light from a star drop
because you see a planet orbit in front
of it sure so photometry just means
measuring light so you can actually have
infrared photometry you're just
measuring the infrared light and you can
have optical photometry which is
measuring the photometry in the optical
part of the spectrum so the way we find
planets with for instance Kepler and now
Tess is transit photometry so what we do
is measure the brightness of the star
over
over again and we wait for the little
dip in the brightness of the star when a
planet goes in front of it now that
relies on the planet being lined up just
right so actually most planets don't
transit which means we need to look for
hundreds of thousands of stars to find
the small number that are lined up just
right so that we can see them so it's
kind of an inefficient survey strategy
but it does mean we get to look at a lot
of stars which makes the stellar
astrophysicists very happy and yeah
because you were just explaining that
even though the star is here the planet
could be orbiting like this around it
not exactly exactly so if you were an
alien civilization looking at the earth
you'd need to be lined up in our
ecliptic in our ecliptic plane which is
where all the planets in our solar
system are there's the constellations of
the zodiac this is all our ecliptic this
is the plane of our solar system if you
imagine the solar systems like a big
pancake we're all in the pancake so the
alien civilization would be need to be
lined up with that pancake to see us
transit so that means we can only see a
certain number of systems transit as
well yeah their solar systems are tilted
but the interesting implication of that
is we know which stars could see us
transit we know which stars if they had
aliens around them would be able to see
us transit and that's really interesting
because those are the sorts of stars we
could concentrate on looking for with
for instance SETI and seeing like in
like hi guys like could we put something
out official in orbit to make an
artificially shaped transit which is one
of the things we've talked about the
signaling like we're here I feel like I
just blew Alan's mind he's just like I
don't even know where to go now there
because just even thinking about the
pancake shapes and how you have to be
perfectly positioned and you know so
Kepler looked at a hundred fifty
thousand stars in one patch of the sky
for eight years and then now there's
this key to the secondary mission that's
going on with it and about like almost
5,000 or so at least identified 2,500
confirmed so I ordered more pending
confirmation 30 of these are so are in
this habitable zone do you think which
is very exciting stuff could be like
Earth
could have evolved intelligence or just
microbial life this type of a thing but
then there's tests which is which is not
which is just looking at the star
systems closest to us and so those are
big differences looking really far away
or versus for a really long time or
looking close just one month at a time
yeah so Kepler and tests really have
different strategies Kepler was a narrow
deep survey like a cone survey or as
tests which just launched in April is an
all-sky survey but a shallow survey so
wide and shallow versus narrow and deep
and test is supposed to look at
something like 2 million 10 million
stars in the first two years for planets
so we're going to find tens of thousands
of planets with tests we're really going
to be able to keep going with our
exponential curve that I was talking
about and really find you know exciting
new things really nearby that's the
exciting thing about testers all the
kepler planets as you said it quite far
away the test planners would be
effectively in our backyard and then
what are we talking about regarding
backyard like 25 mm let years away more
like 10 to 100 light years away so yeah
so the kepler planets are a thousand
dish light-years away
so even Kepler only really probed our
local neighborhood if you think about
the size of our galaxy the galaxy is a
hundred thousand light-years across and
we're about thirty thousand light-years
from the middle
Kepler's only looked out to about three
thousand light years
so the we've only searched like a little
bubble right around us in terms of our
galaxy Tess is going to search an even
smaller bubble but we'll be able to
study the planets that test finds in
much more detail which is the exciting
part yeah and then okay so now let's
well let's talk about what we've been
finding because as you catalog and
archive these exoplanets there's there
seem to be some very interesting things
that you've discovered as you're doing
so so I teach us about that sure so you
know as we were talking about before
1995 we didn't really know about planets
around other stars and all of our
theories about how we build planets how
we find planets systems would sign about
around our solar system designed to find
systems where you had rocky planets that
were around our size
and then gas giants around Jupiter and
Saturn sighs all of our theories were
how do we reproduce the solar system but
when we went out there I know right when
we went out there we found everything
but we found this incredible diversity
of different types of worlds we found
hot Jupiters which is when you take a
jupiter-sized planet and you park it
right next to the star so it goes around
at star every 2 or 3 days compared to
Jupiter which takes 12 years we found
lava worlds so balls of rock the size of
Earth that are thousands of degrees so
hot that the surface must be molten
there's literally like a little ball of
lava traveling around its host star
we found compact systems of planets
where you find five planets all with
periods shorter than 13 days so in our
solar system mercury is the closest
planet and it has a period of 88 days
this is five planets within 13 days just
imagine how tightly packed those planets
are so we've just found this incredible
diversity and nothing like we predicted
which is the exciting part you know job
security finding all of these these
planets out there which keep us thinking
and keep us imagining and keep us
building new theories for how we would
how would you even create a hot Jupiter
for instance and I really like how the
discoveries of planets orbiting stars
which every star has about one at least
one planet and then about every five
stars you'll find an earth-like planet
potentially so I really like how this
has a lot to do with the simulation or
running simulation just because there's
so many variables and that you get
thrown into all these different styles
of single star systems or binary star
systems or bhoot hot Jupiters or yeah
this is very exciting because it it
expands our minds new dimensions of
thinking and possibility so I really
like that aspect to it so okay so out of
all of the like 5000 then what are like
I guess are like trends that we're
seeing you see we're saying hot Jupiters
what are what are we thinking is there
something like Oh a thousand of them are
like really far away from their star or
something like that sure so there are a
few different trends that are emerging
one is that stars that have
lot of heavy elements compared to our
Sun seem to make bigger planets so
that's kind of interesting and it might
be intuitive you know if there's more
heavy elements that makes you know you
can make a bigger planetary core which
then can a creep more gas which it ends
up having a bigger planet other trends
are that smaller stars seem to have more
rocky planets around them so M dwarfs
are the new hot place to look for
habitable earth-like planets so we we
live around a G star our star is just a
big yellow G star
but yeah the og the og star I love it
but most of the stars so yeah so it's
just it's weird sequence which has a
very nowadays not very politically
correct mnemonic for remembering it OB
AF g/km is then is the stars so o stars
are the biggest bluest brightest stars
yes so so and like Sirius oh this is big
stars and then so our star is a G star
and then at the very end of that
sequence is M so M s are smaller they're
like they can be 10% to 50% the size of
our Sun they're much cooler so 3,000
degrees instead of five and a half
thousand degrees like our Sun and
something like 75% of the stars in the
galaxy are M dwarfs they're actually the
most numerous kind of star and the
exciting thing about them is you can put
yes so actually as far as we know no M
star has ever gotten to the end of its
life just given the age of the universe
and how long M stars live for all the M
stars ever born is still alive I know
that's pretty cool and it has really
cool implications for like if they have
habitable rocky worlds around them that
civilization could live for a really
long time you know every time I give a
talk to schoolchildren about planets
someone's like I hear that in five
billion years the Sun is going to expand
which it will and you know maybe we'll
have solved all the problems by then but
like if you were orbiting an M star you
don't have that problem for a very very
long time even longer than five billion
years so we're excited about M dwarfs
because it's easier to find rocky
habitable planets around M dwarfs the
relative size of the planet in the star
is much easier for us to see and the
planet can be much closer and still be
habitable like a now soulless
if you took the earth and moved it to
the orbit of mercury it would be way too
hot there'd be no liquid water we'd all
you know we live in Southern California
so we already know what that feels like
but that would be a bad but if we had an
M star in the center of our solar system
we could get very close and still be
habitable so we could have an orbit of
two weeks and still be habitable instead
of a year yeah so the interesting thing
about other stars is they don't live
very long
they you know maybe a million years so
maybe that's not long enough yeah
they're quite like the big ones just
come and go super fast and so maybe
that's not enough time to develop life
like maybe you can't get life around our
stars so that's interesting yeah exactly
exactly in the lifetime of the star and
the sort of radiation that it puts out
the problem with M dwarfs were growing
slightly off-topic
the problem with M dwarfs is that they
put out a lot more UV radiation than our
Sun so the way life has evolved on earth
you know UV can disrupt our DNA it can
cause mutations and M stars put out
thousands of times more UV radiation so
could you evolve life like our life if
we were orbiting an M style that would
if we have very delicate DNA what is
ours our planets orbitting M dwarfs just
sterile because we actually use UV light
on earth to sterilize clean rooms
because it kills everything it's bad so
this is one of the downsides of M and
dwarf planets like they're easier to
find but maybe they're all sterilized
because of the radiation so that's an
open question we're still working that
out okay so the trends are okay sure so
we find big planets around stars that
have lots of heavy elements so it so
stars that are the size of our Sun can
have a variety of amounts of heavy
elements from very little to a lot even
though the star itself is the same size
the same temperature looks the same it
can have different different composition
and so the stars where we see them have
more heavy elements they seem to have
more giant planets around them like
Jupiter sized planet
another one is that M Dwarfs seem to
have more rocky planets around them so
systems like Trappist
Trappist is an M dwarf that has seven
rocky planets around it yes or quite
close and so that's another one that we
see out of the 5000 is there about like
a thousand or so of these M Dwarfs or
how many oh that's a good question um I
don't think there's that many because
there aren't a lot of bright M stars
that's the other thing about M stars is
are all quite faint I think most of the
planets are actually around G and K
stars so our star and slightly and like
75% the size of our star so most of them
around that and that's mostly because
Kepler found to them and Kepler focused
on those kinds of stars out of the
150,000 stars that Kepler looked at only
3000 where M dwarfs know this is that
was that's a bit on the actual like
cattle cataloging and archiving I think
I think maybe maybe you should tell us a
bit about the process of of taking a
planet and confirming it how many times
you have to see it dim the light before
you confirm it and then what it means to
update it and retract it sure so when
you see a dip you get really excited
when you see two dips you get very very
excited and when you see three dips
you're pretty sure you know that it's a
single transiting body one thing that's
going around three and you've seen it
three times so you're pretty sure you
want to see at least three transits but
still all you know at that point is that
something is transiting something you
need to do you need to know the masses
of those two things to really confirm
that it's a planet and not like a small
star or you can have two big stars where
one star is just grazing the bottom of
the other star and causing a little dip
even though it's a very big star so what
we need to do then is go and measure the
mass and there's a few different ways of
doing that the most common way is to
examine the star itself so when a
planets orbiting a star it's actually
pulling the star around in a circle in
our solar system Jupiter is pulling the
Sun around so if you were again an alien
civilization looking at our Sun you
would see the Sun trace out a circle
every 12 years which is the orbit of
Jupiter
exactly so so measuring the speed of the
Sun away towards you and away from you
is measuring its Doppler effect so
that's what we do we look at these stars
and we try to measure their speed are
they moving towards us or away from us
are they doing it periodically is that
the same period as the transiting thing
we see and then you can work out how
massive the body is that's pulling on it
and that tells you whether or not it's a
planet
so that's the most common way of
confirming a planet you want to see
three transits and then go measure its
mass and tada planet sure so usually as
soon as you've got a mass you you
publish your paper you're good
but a lot of these planets we want to
study more we want to get better
parameters we want to find out more
about their atmospheres what they're
made of so often people will use bigger
and better telescopes or get more data
and refine the analysis or they'll come
up with a new modeling method that's
quite common like a new way of turning
the data into parameters and so then
they'll publish updates so one of the
other things I do on the exoplanet
archive is trawl all of the published
literature for the best set of
parameters for each planet so people
publish a new set and I have to look at
it and look at our current set and be
like okay these are better and here's
why the other thing that can happen is
people go and look at this planet again
and get more data and realize they made
a mistake realize that what they thought
was a planet that actually
misinterpreted something else like
stellar activity the stars are also
doing their own things like rotating and
flaring and all this kind of stuff or
the transit that you saw was just a
glitch in the instrument it wasn't real
so then people publish retractions so
people say okay we went and looked at
this planet again and it turns out it's
actually not there so we should strike
that one out so part of my job I'm kind
of like the gatekeeper at NASA's XO pond
archive I'm looking to see which ones
I'm letting in and which ones I'm taking
back out which ones I'm updating it's
great that's a really important job and
like you're like you're saying there has
to be really solid evidence for it to be
brought in and it's good that it's good
that that we're actually pursuing this
like retraction as well if we're going
in were double triple checking okay
so what is the so you were talking about
the what what Tess is going to do would
and it's already doing looking at in in
in a elliptical patch of the which which
which way yeah yeah teach us about that
okay
so Tess has four cameras and they make a
big rectangle on the sky basically the
rectangle is about ninety degrees so
like a right angle and it's about 25
degrees wide so it's this big swath of
the sky that it does in one hit and then
it rotates slightly and does the next
one and then it rotates and does the
next one and then the next one and then
the next one and it's going to spend one
year one year doing that whole
hemisphere of the sky first it's doing
the southern hemisphere and then it's
doing the northern hemisphere but yes
each patch that it stares at it's
staring out for one month yes it's got
four cameras and this camera at the top
is always on the pole on the on the
elliptic on the ecliptic poles so as its
turning around those stars at the pole
are always being observed so for the
stars down near the ecliptic they'll
only get observed for a month because
that camera will move around but the
stars at the poles we get observed for a
year because that camera will always be
observing them yeah so we'll be
sensitive to longer period planets at
the poles than we are at the ecliptic so
then the actual size of tasks has got
four of these cameras on it so that
means that that by camera it's not a
mirror or is it there is a mirror on the
back of the camera and then it and then
it reflects the light onto a silicon
again and then yeah yes so it's so ten
centimeter telescopes basically there's
four ten centimeter telescopes each of
them is fairly standard optical design
but yes it's reflecting the light onto
four CCDs
so four different and 10 centimeters
four inches that's not very big because
the point is that Kepler told us that
planets are everywhere most stars have
planets as you said and we only want our
looking with tests at the brightest ones
the most nearby ones so we didn't need a
huge telescope and that was one of the
reasons why we were able to do tests on
the budget that we did it was because
you only needed little telescopes oh
sweet
okay so so we have certain candidates
now that are like ten to a hundred light
years away that we think are really high
likelihood yeah so we have some very
nearby planets that we were excited
about for instance our very closest star
Proxima Centauri is 3.8 light-years away
and it has a rocky planet in the
habitable zone so already our very close
to star planet right there and tests
just yesterday brought out its first
planet around a star that's only I think
12 light-years away so that's really
close as well so that's really exciting
the point of test is to find all of our
nearest neighbors it's very exciting
and then further image them later time
with the James Webb and stuff like that
okay so a lot of the EXO Cal conference
that's going on right now is about
detection to characterization okay so
now we've made detections and now we're
gonna start characterizing them you were
giving us some characterizations earlier
of M dwarfs and of very bright stars as
well that star spectrum and then planets
some rocky some hot Jupiters okay that's
okay so now now as we characterize them
do like how do how do how do they even
get filtered into the different buckets
and yeah sure so there are there are
kind of gross demographic buckets that
you can put them in like this is big and
this is small but one of the exciting
things that we're seeing now is we're
starting to say okay if we take a bunch
of the small ones how do we divvy those
that what are the what are the things
that define them and we can find groups
like oh these all have a lot of carbon
in their atmospheres or these all have a
lot of methane in their atmospheres like
that's the level that we're getting to
now which is really exciting because now
we're starting to understand the physics
that's going on in terms of the
formation processes and the evolution
process is like how do you end up with
an atmosphere that looks like this this
is like you know dozens of light-years
away then more and how are we how do we
have the tools to be able to see what's
in their atmosphere oh that's a really
good question so we have two ways of so
far we have two ways of finding out
what's in a planet's atmosphere one is
looking
it's transmission so when a planet is
going in front of a star the star light
will stream through the planet's
atmosphere at certain wavelengths the
molecules in the atmosphere will block
the light those are the wavelengths that
speak to those molecules but at other
wavelengths the light will come through
so the planet will transmit light so we
can look at the light that gets
transmitted by the planets and
reverse-engineer what molecules must be
in the atmosphere of the planet in order
to give us this signature this spectrum
of the planet that's right so it's
actually really interesting the planet
looks different sizes in different
wavelengths because it's some
wavelengths the atmosphere is full of
molecules that are blocking the light
and it's some wavelengths it's
transparent so you see you effectively
see deeper into the planet's atmosphere
so the planet what we actually do is
measure the size of the planet as a
function of wavelength and that's our
spectrum tells us what molecules need to
be there so that's really cool one of
the other ways we can find out what's in
a planet's atmosphere is is the reverse
so when the planet goes around behind
the star right before it eclipses well
before the star actually blocks the
light the light is being reflected off
the planet's surface and back to us and
that tells us something different so you
know it probes a different part of the
planet's atmosphere but it's similar in
the sense that some wavelengths of light
will be absorbed and some will be
reflected and that will depend on what
molecules are in the atmosphere of the
planet so that's the emission of the
planet so we look for the planets
transmission and its emission and then
the the the tool that is that is used
for that is the same photometers that's
a good question we often use different
tools for those because they're kind of
in different wavelength regimes so we've
used the Hubble Space Telescope to do a
lot of transmission spectroscopy so this
is looking at the light that goes
through the planet's atmosphere and
we've used the Spitzer Space Telescope
which looks in the infrared to observe a
lot of the emitted light and that's
mostly because the emission is the
strongest in the infrared a lot of these
planets that we're looking at it quite
hot by virtue of the fact that they're
often very close to their star so that
the light that they're emitting is very
hot so we can see them better in the
infrared then we can see them in the
optical so they're actually different
instruments but they're both NASA space
telescopes that we use a lot Hubble and
Spitzer and when James Webb launches
few years James Webb will be able to do
this in an exquisite detail because it's
a much bigger telescope but you know
three times the size of Hubble which
means effectively ten times a collective
area so it'll be able to really really
start to measure the atmospheres of
smaller and smaller and cooler planets
so the cooler a planet is the hotter it
is to look at its atmosphere okay so so
good okay maybe maybe this is important
to also talk about there the future of
top of what we're of what we're doing
with space you were mentioning James
Webb's going up with whatever it is like
22-foot mirror six and a half metre
mirror that's so big it's amazing and
then the and it's gonna like fold out
all cool once they get shipped up like
that's stuff so interesting yeah yeah
yeah let's get that thing launched and
then there's all these other interesting
sort of methods of like blocking out the
Starlight with like star shades and
choreography so maybe teach us about
that sure so the ways that I've talked
about measuring planets and detecting
planets so far have been very indirect
we're looking at the star and we're
looking for the impact of the planet on
the star either the planet blocks some
of the Starlight or the planet pulls on
the star one of the best ways the
clearest way is the most unambiguous way
is to look at planets would be to block
out the Starlight so you don't see the
star at all and you just see the planet
and that's very difficult because stars
are typically a billion times brighter
than the planet that's orbiting them so
that's a very that's a very difficult
contrast ratio to measure so we've come
up with a lot of technical solutions to
this where you try and block the
wavelength of the block the star light
from the star at certain wavelengths and
you can either do that as Alan said by
launching a star shade which is a very
big thing that you launch far away from
your spacecraft that blocks the star
light but it's got this very specific
shape so it lets some of the light
through the light from the planet or you
can actually put a blocker in your
instrument like a little coronagraph in
front of your lens
sort of these next sort of advancements
in technology are going to enable us to
image exoplanets much better that's the
idea we have this vision that in 20 to
30 years time we launch a spacecraft
which is able to take the first image of
an earth-like planet around another star
actually see these planets and actually
look at them and that will be incredible
I mean that'll give us the answers to
many more questions and we can answer
right now you guys heard it here first
get that funding in for more space
instruments as soon as possible as soon
as possible okay as we come to an end I
want to talk a bit about space economy
stuff this seems like we're moving in
the direction of more and more people we
were just announced the first person
there japanese guy that's going to go in
space echo SpaceX's rocket around the
moon bring some artists hopefully those
artists can create inspirational works
of art that can then inspire other
people to care more about space and care
more about that we are one sort of
effect on earth so yeah what are you
what do you most looking forward to in
this space account we already we already
have all these small satellite companies
and all this other kind of cool stuff
the ISS is having more projects come to
it and all this kind of stuff so what
are you most looking forward sure well I
mean even test has already benefited
from the privatization of space that was
launched on a falcon 9 in April in April
of this year so what I'm looking forward
to is the privatization of space
bringing costs down for launching
exciting science experiments for us
that's it I don't want it to go too far
I would worry if space was left entirely
to the hands of private companies that
you know then all of the goals and
achievements in space would be very
limited in scope like it's fantastic
that they're sending artists to space
that's great and you know at some point
they're going to be sending miners to
space to like plug you know look at
asteroids and and plunder all of their
precious metals but you know so I want
to make sure that there's a mix a mix I
think is the healthiest idea so some
privatization so that you can take more
risks than for instance NASA can part of
the reason why privatization is good is
because NASA is spending taxpayers
so we can't be very risky with it
because that would be terrible but
private is private companies are can
take forests they can they can be more
you know innovative NASA is always
launching technology that was actually
perfected like 15 years earlier which
means we're never actually launching the
cutting-edge thing that's like exciting
right now because we had it has to be
tested and reliable and probably planned
into the proposal a decade early before
it actually got selected and then tested
and then funded and then built but
companies like SpaceX can be flying the
latest thing I just want to make sure
that the public has to say as well in
what's happening in space and that we
educate people to the extent at which we
can make really good decisions about
what's going on in space you also we
didn't you telling me about this before
but you were like actually I've been
working on tests for quite a while it's
not just since April because it takes a
long time for missions to get completely
engineered and designed and then funded
and then actually doing the the putting
together of all the mechanical and
electrical and computational pieces and
then going on to space and then
collecting the data so this is a very
very long process that sometimes you can
only get you'll only work on like three
of these missions in your life or
something like that okay question that
we typically ask on the show what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world so I'm biased because I'm a mother
of two twin three-year-olds so for me
the most beautiful thing in the world is
healthy children and keeping them that
way for as long as possible happy is
good too but healthy is the is the main
pot yes happy and healthy kids happy
healthy life yeah that's a good one and
what do you think we can do to maximize
the potential of especially young girls
into our world so something that I feel
really strongly about is the
under-representation of women in the
STEM fields and that hurts everybody it
doesn't just hurt women it hurts
everybody because it means that we're
lopping off at least 50% of our creative
intellectual potential by doing this by
you know by not exploiting everything
that we have so I think that starting as
young as possible is the is that is the
key
I was just telling Alan before even at 3
years old my kids are already being
stereotyped
and that's very frustrating because at
three years old they are still lumps and
they're very moldable and I don't want
them to be molded into my daughter
thinking I can't do science and my son
thinking I can't cry like I want to so
just as young as possible we need to be
breaking these Serio types breaking
these molds not letting society
condition our children into thinking
that they have to be in a box it's it's
easy to say but it's so pernicious you
just see it everywhere that this is
happening and I don't you know I can't
solve society's gender problem with one
sentence but just starting as young as
possible I think and being aware of it
and trying to step in when it happens
that's all I'm trying to do and I mean
this probably I probably already know
your answer but you do think we're alone
in the cosmos I don't think we're alone
in the cosmos I'd be surprised if we
were alone given the millions and
billions of planets out there I'm
surprised we haven't heard from anyone
yet if we are alone probably my gut is
that there is microbial life commonly
throughout the galaxy but there's some
reason why we never get to be a you know
galaxy faring civilization and we don't
know what that is yet and do you think
that potentially we are in a simulation
I don't think we'd be able to tell so
it's kind of a meaningless distinction
it's a fun question but you know it
doesn't change anything if we are
because we wouldn't be able to tell
because what kind of simulation would
that be so it's fun to think about but I
don't think we can tell and this has
been something that's been on my radar
now for just a little while this idea
that as a civilization becomes so
intelligent that and they get to the
singularity that they just go inward
they don't want to go outward they can
travel the cosmos technologically
simulation wise maybe rather than
actually going and physically doing it
do you think that that might be an
answer to the Fermi paradox it could be
I don't think we have a way to rule it
out yet I don't think it's the only
answer to the Fermi paradox it's kind of
one of the more depressing ones it's
only slightly less depressing
then we nuke ourselves in the next 10
years like maybe every intelligent
civilization just tears itself apart
which given that is 2018
not not looking too unlikely I tagged
your note on Twitter when I said that
isn't it likely that they just don't
know how to work together if they
evolved intelligently and they can't
figure it out because there's too much
war and hate instead of that love and
then we'll and then just do you think we
have to reach like zoo hypothesis we
have to reach like teleportation or
something for them to start talking to
us because they don't want to ruin the
evolutionary experiment that is really
hard to speculate about because we don't
have any information we haven't seen an
example of that on earth given all of
the different types of things that we've
seen we've never we've never really held
back from colonizing have we so it's
it's hard to imagine but obviously if it
was an alien if it was truly alien we
wouldn't we would have difficulty
imagining it anyway and I mean we
already see it in our own solar system
we already want to get out there to the
next planet to the next thing but going
to Europa now and it's like where does
it stop so it's hard to imagine that
that but that could be the answer that
we're in a zoo and that we're [ __ ]
being left alone to evolve the prime
directive version I that's that's tricky
in part because I feel like we'd have
seen evidence of something by now if
there was a giant galactic civilization
out there just kind of holding back it
might just be that the laws of physics
are brutal and it's really hard to
explore interstellar distances and
people just kind of realize that they
can't in in in an efficient way yeah
that is a lot of exoplanet cataloging
and archiving and analysis good times
with just Christensen and the NASA
exoplanet archive and cataloging system
this is there's still so much to
discover with tasks out there now and
even with all the data that we have no
no now it's time to image the
atmospheres and we're very grateful
because we'll have Stephen cane on the
show in a little bit
yes yes so we're really excited for that
and to chat with him a bit more about
actually understanding the habitability
and that will be very exciting so thanks
everyone thanks Jesse thank you for
coming on the show greatly appreciate it
huge thank you
and everyone thank you for tuning in if
you guys had a good time let us know
what your thoughts are below we'd love
to hear from you don't just consume this
content go and create with it go and
make art with it go make music with it
go make videos with they go start
businesses with their going start cool
stuff go create thank you everyone and
we'll see you soon